I actually I have a whole Theory
I have okay I have a whole theory that
like the church is actually like a
homemaker and like it's actually like a
a breeding ground for hoes and I'll tell
you what I'll tell you why okay because
it's like what they'll do is they'll
have these chastities and I remember
being in high school because I've always
been me you know I've always kind of
like thought the way I do but I was just
like a young Pearl in high school and we
had this Chastity speaker and I was
thinking like basically she went up and
she said I got ran through but then I
found God you know praise God and then
the husband was like and then the
husband was like oh yeah and I I found
her after this and like I was a virgin
and I waited and she and it's oh and I
realized I was like it's always the
women who didn't wait and I'm like oh
it's like they're kind of marketing you
can be a hoe and then find a husband
like it's like a marketing like I don't
think they mean to but I'm like oh it's
like that's what they're marketing to
young women and I remember like wanting
to like ask this question but Catholic
School couldn't handle but you're saying
and so then and so then it's like on top
of that the pastors have this reputation
for screwing the congregation right
that's like that's like yeah that's like
that's that's a common thing I guess it
wasn't it was I've heard it I've heard
it I've heard it here I've heard it in
both places but and I'm like why is
there The Stereotype they must do it a
lot right Justin Bieber's like priest or
whatever Pastor came out and I'm like no
wonder they preach forgiveness because
he wants to screw all the hoes and so
what he's saying is he's saying all of
you guys can wait I'm gonna screw them
and add to the bodies and then you guys
can all marry him after I'm done and
that's that's my kind of preacher and
that's why I have this theory that like
a church is really like that's why
that's why the guys will because the
guys will all tell me the girls are
worse in the church and I'm like why
would they be worse because they
basically Market that you can be a hoe
forever and then get a husband at the
end and so then all the hoes go so
you're saying there's a whole show so
it's a whole show yeah yeah yeah it's a
whole show yeah
must have come back from Brixton must
not go into Brixton from the night
before to get the men and nine times out
of ten those women in church get run
through by the men that are visiting
because they got a habit and the mother
and the mothers and the mother and the
mothers and the mothers don't forget the
mothers you know because the mothers
yeah will encourage them to look your
best your Sunday Best in other words
imagine if the pastors came forward okay
imagine if they said okay like because
they're like they'll say they'll say you
could be saved right like the like the
hoes they'll be like hoes come to church
maybe they don't say it like that so
they basically say hoes come to church
because you can be forgiven for
everything imagine if they said men
don't accept that don't you like wait
for the next round of women leave them
right they will what
no you're right you're right that's why
like that's why I've got there aren't a
lot of guys in general walk into any
church at 70 to 80 women but just
imagine if they flipped it and they said
don't accept that for like the same way
they'll tell men and I can't I'm trying
to articulate this right but the same
way they'll tell women like your husband
should be this this this he should be
equally yoked to man of God blah blah
blah blah blah but it's like they don't
say to the men don't date these ran
through girls don't do it you don't
deserve that you deserve better you
should date this this and this like it's
always what the women should expect from
a husband you know what because the men
that go to church have less bloody count
than the women that go to church yeah I
know but no but I think that's why
though because the men that actually
understand female nature they think this
is nonsense it's all the symptoms
you know what we call these women a
doors and we don't know what to do so
you know we've got to make some weight
like men they're really nice they're
Christians that you take them because
nobody else outside church is going to
want them so they might as well take the
ones no I I think they want to keep the
women single in the church because they
have to make money off of them like each
each girl gives how much a week and like
that's that's the thing and it's kind of
like it's weird because they ask for
donations but when there's more single
homeless women over the age of like
that's the fastest growing homeless
population single women and so if
they're if they're giving like a hundred
bucks a week let's say that's 400 a
month times up by a year that that's a
retirement account go ahead similar I
don't want to say it similar to a club
environment the more attractive women
you attracted
willing with the hand open mental tables
is good it's got more money right so the
men are gonna come and spend their money
millions of Charity books because like
when you're younger when you're younger
it's like you're not necessarily just
going to your local church you're going
to the popular church the church that's
popping yeah that's got that young
good-looking environment that's the one
you're going and you're going there in
your best you're waking up early Sunday
morning in your drip like what yo
I remember being in and I've always been
me so I've always had these thoughts but
I remember being like younger and they
would say make a list of the things you
want in your future husband and I'm like
why don't they say that to the men make
a list of what you want in your future
wife but the problem is none of the
girls in the congregation can meet that
hmm
so basically all these women just go
into church to find the good guys
because they're tired of all the bad
boys I think I think that's
a common response but a lot of times
hear it from from guys that it's 28 29
30 right when time's running out is when
they tend to go to church and if they do
get to church young they leave right
when they get to college and so it's
like that's your attractions I'm not
talking about my church I'm talking
about General feedback I wouldn't even
say I'm crazy religious but I'm saying
that's General feedback I've just gotten
from men like their exp like different
churches same experience
wow those are my churches because my
teaching I've seen so many churches with
young people I don't know I didn't see
the evidence
who said their church at night
someone from your church a girl is
busting up with a man right now from
your church because human beings
she listen didn't you say they're going
to church to get husband and all that
buttocks that's something yeah that's
not the reason
you could do that for your yard you
could do that no but no you know people
not everyone believes that I'm not I'm
not gonna say are you on the topic of
going to church and making it all about
like relationships and stuff I when I
went to church I recently found God
properly and started going church and
stuff and it had nothing to do with no
man no relationship it was because I was
dealing with my own internal traumas and
God was my backbone God was my safe
place so I wanted to explore what type
of trauma was it was it good no ft no it
wasn't I don't know what that is um
[Laughter]
you see that's what I'm telling you guys
got it to see comfort you know no but we
go there to see Christ my last point and
then I stopped is that I feel like for
me it's because I've had it emotional
trauma I was learning more about God at
home and I wanted to go to church more
because I wanted to learn more from
people who have spent years studying it
preaching it mastering it that sort of
stuff so my point is I'm just saying it
ain't always about this sexualization or
of women going to church have a back of
bad relationships because not not every
woman you might you might not say it's
not all women I I agree with you it's
just funny when women always seem to
come after a whole phase that's just
what I've heard from the men it's just
it's just interesting how right after
the whole phase now you're here
fascinating I went to church when I when
I was younger and my dad's made me go
and I went and I had a good time and
then as I got older I kind of dropped it
out and I went for a time in my life in
2013 and um I feel like a lot of people
speak to God when their balls deep in
the [ __ ] or when they when they need a
bit of guidance or I need a bit of help
not like oh God you know I'm doing good
and XYZ I feel like back then I looked
so good to help me in a situation and
God's told me that the outcome that I
wanted to happen ain't gonna happen and
guess what it never happened good was
right and from then I said you know what
there was someone up there I'm not crazy
so I am a Christian and from a young age
my stepdad wanted me my dad wanted me to
be a Christian but I feel like I find
that space Within Myself and I don't go
church but I'm still a Christian and I
didn't go to church fan dick I was like
10 or 10 you know what I mean
as many of you know I was just just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible